yeah it's crazy bandits cancel culture
shows Wow oh brother it's you know I you
know III think about it a lot you know
because because I try to I just try to
understand so much because I want to
understand a lot of perspectives I want
I want to try to like understand and if
you know a lot of times yeah I don't
click with it and I think the reason why
I don't click with it because like I
think my stepfather was abusive he was
abusive his [ __ ] you know what I mean
and but I don't want to go after him you
know I don't want to go like because
like I think about like when I would
like I went through I had to go I have
had three different anger management
teachers and oh [ __ ] you got some real
anger yeah yeah I would say anger
management for about eight weeks because
I got yeah I punched a window oh do and
I had to go I went to court and then
they put me I had to go to anger
management off Country Club in
University I'll see if I was through
like I remember where that task is where
we have to go pick that's ready to go um
I had to go through the schools I want
to okay so what were you say so you were
sorry back to what you were saying no
but yeah like okay so my anger
management teacher they didn't teach me
to go after people they taught me to go
after myself so like that's why I don't
connect with trying to cancel someone
like that I like I don't want it like
you know I don't blame my biological
father for not being around those years
like I gotta blame my mom for like when
she stayed with my stepdad because it's
like I don't know it I'd rather I'd
rather you know I don't either make my
life cool on my own then why right
because then you're relying on other
people's choices for your happiness yeah
like like yeah save my stepfather you
know like yeah I I wouldn't give him
people a lot of power yeah yeah exactly
like say yeah went after him you know he
ends up going to prison for the [ __ ]
blah blah how does that make you better
ten years afternoon do it does it like
it literally does nothing for me like I
didn't do I didn't do anything for me
I did it because I was I don't like him
but it's like why so
right you know that like like I said I
try to understand everything you know I
try to be completely honest yeah
everything about me I think that there's
a lot of stuff where it's like okay man
there's definitely people who do [ __ ]
you know what you're like okay well
you're a piece of [ __ ] and I mean you
get aired out all day like I there's you
know there's a lot of that you know that
I'm like yeah I agree with but then
there's a certain [ __ ] where it's like
like wait wait like you can never make a
mistake yeah like that like I was like
the one I think about like a lot is like
that Kevin Hart situation like crazy
he had old insensitive tweets but like
back then like dude if like you know and
obviously nobody likes to slur gay
people love gay people mm-hmm
like Eminem couldn't put albums out
anymore oh if like we went back and like
held people to the same standards we
hold them today
well like well the thing is like how
come no one looked post that tweet like
like like after that tweet like why
didn't anyone like look at his life in
the way he is after that oh yeah like
what are they why did they define him
off you if you looked at here you go oh
here's a dump that was the last time he
did something yeah wait you're like the
person could have put the person was the
person could have done it's been like oh
man Kevin Hart used to talk like this
and he doesn't anymore man he's like he
grew he grew it's so awesome that people
can grow good change
yeah we like you know I think a lot of
people are just because they can't go
after someone else that they I think
that is a little bit more closer to them
so they try to I think they just go
after these people and try to make this
like thing me I'm I'm unapologetic it's
[ __ ] like me to me you like out I don't
like I don't have a fear of like not
being liked or not being you know I
think to what's great about like being
in your position is like you have your
own platform you're also comedian so
it's like you're sir I I want my
comedians to say offensive things yeah
well cause like like you think about the
Chappelle special that came out with his
trans bit and how
really funny like it's not coming from a
place of hatred but he's a he's a
comedian and he's supposed to make fun
of people yeah that's all people that's
the thing about comedy the reason why
it's funny cuz we're saying [ __ ]
differently we're gonna say it in a way
that not everybody is thinking yeah so
we're always thinking of it in a
different way and and every time a
comedian writes a joke no comedians
writing a joke to go and I want to
[ __ ] bash on these people no comedian
does that and if you're trying to write
a joke because damn that's funny
the intent is funny and then there
what's the one guy uh what's his name
the guy who made the [ __ ] up Kobe joke
on Twitter when he died
Oh Ari Shaffir yeah that guy that guy's
not just not funny like hey bro like
what were you thinking but do I think he
deserves get canceled no like he lost
music yeah it was a horrible horrible
Joe horrible Joe and even if it wasn't a
joke like he just you know he didn't he
didn't even have to do this read the
room buddy yeah read the [ __ ] room
sometimes you just got to read the room
yeah yeah but you but I agree with you
like like I don't [ __ ] with that dude
because of what he said cuz I'm like yo
he's probably not that great of a guy
plus I plead bpp [ __ ] poison the Bert
guy with some drugs over yeah which was
like bro what kind of guy does that what
the [ __ ] I'm just not gonna I don't have
to support the guy he should go get
booked but it like here's the thing that
people don't realize about conveniens
like you got to think of comedians as
like like like like TV you got a lot of
channels yeah I don't like I don't like
you know I'm not a big friend's guy
exactly I thought two and a Half Men was
trash
but guess what people like it that's
okay that's how you got to think of
comedy so like I don't have like like I
don't like get weird like like I've had
like one lady you know come up to me
after a show cuz she was offended by a
joke and I was just like okay you're at
a cup you should be offense like people
she wanted a battle and I was just like
okay there's no point you can put any
energy there yeah because what I knew I
liked
I know my intentions yeah I know where
I'm coming from
I know who I am yeah and I know what I'm
saying and first of all you can't pick
and choose throughout my set of what you
thought was offensive or not there'd be
no time to live if people did that with
everything in their life
oh and there's people who do that yeah
they do you know they're gonna do I'll
tell you what cuz I bet I used to be
like my anger I used to just pop you
know what I mean it was just a lot of
issues because I was sensitive to like
you know I thought everybody needed a
like you know to my needs but you know
you get exhausted yeah because I used to
be the same way where I would like I
would like argue with people on Facebook
which is the worst [ __ ] oh brother
I would I would some [ __ ] or somebody
would try to say some slick [ __ ] some
local rappers and I would just am I
giving energy to this [ __ ] because it's
because I know it's so funny cuz I know
conversation is authentic over the
internet never think about it
like you didn't you didn't hit me up to
do this podcast to go hey we're gonna
we're gonna do it over Twitter though
right
you know I mean that doesn't doesn't
make any sense so it's like you know
when people like go back and like I
don't know you if someone if someone
tells me hey this happened and then I go
how do you know like how you know that's
true and then they go we'll go look at
Twitter I'll slap them in the face
cuz I hate that [ __ ] ya know it's crazy
just says it's just also people just get
their information from these places like
and then yeah and they hang their hat on
it
I have like my mom will send me [ __ ] she
sees on Facebook I'll be like mom mom
get the [ __ ] off face sure my mom was
like literally black yo I don't I don't
know if the coronaviruses real Kevin I'm
like mom stop going on face stable you
know exactly where she was that yeah my
kill you you know your Facebook me on
Facebook mom stay the [ __ ] off of
Facebook yeah like but most old people
get [ __ ] off of Facebook
yeah one it's like they're [ __ ] it's
like their new source no matter what
side of the spectrum you are politically
you hey old people ruin Facebook it's
the worst set of all whatever and then
it's cuz there's also people who you
like actually know in real life and
you're like [ __ ] this guy is a real
piece of [ __ ] damn I knew this guy I
mean follow like like I know this guy
real life Twitter's like people that are
never gonna meet Twitter's a joke yeah
like okay your family you at yeah
exactly
people a real brave on Twitter real
brave